the left dumbing down education in
America in the name of equity high
school students in Blue State Oregon
won't have to prove basic Mastery of
Reading Writing or math in order to
graduate from high school that's because
the state's woke Board of Education
decided unanimously to Nix the standards
and site harm to students of color the
dumb down rules won't kick in for five
years and it's a big slap in the face to
dozens of oregonians who are opposed and
it comes at a terrible time for or kids
who are struggling to read 72% of Oregon
fourth and eighth graders do not meet
Proficiency in reading for their grade
level Greg Gutfeld yes what is happening
in Oregon we warned you that Equity is
not equality equality means you start at
the same place which is easy compared to
equity which means you finish at the
same place which is statistically
impossible because we're individuals we
cannot end at the same place so if you
want Equity that means you you have to
push the end point all the way to the
weakest performer and that creates
incompetence and there go your actual
standards this is by the way the college
demonstrations and equity and this
Equity delusion they are connected if
you remove academic standards all you
have is indoctrination if you replace
hard work and achievement with ego
attention and self-importance you end up
with these mindless delusional
protesters they're indoctrinated
troubled Souls because they're not
learning anything we were PID replace
history with hysteria it's time for
parents to wake up and look at how you
vote look at the campuses look at the
unions and you need to ask yourself is
there a party for parents because you're
replacing geometry with gender and that
ain't going to help them in the
workplace jinny and it's also making the
parents have their kids read give the
kid a book over summer vacation it can't
all be up to the schools you know what
they're doing they're creating
inequality in the name of equity that's
what they're doing they're basically
saying look if you're a minority you're
not going to do as well and you know so
when you come out of the womb just put
them on that track they won't do as well
that is as racist as you can get and
this is the state of Oregon now this is
my thought if the teachers union had
anything to do with this it's an
admission of their failure and if they
weren't part of this the decision you
should fire them anyway because the kids
aren't learning anything because right
now the schools are nothing more than
daycare centers right and it's
determined you know that that these kids
are this color and therefore you know we
can't bother with them let's just push
them out of the system so what does that
mean for the kids who were coming in are
they going to get a good education or
are they going to continue with this
belief that you know what we don't have
to do that much why aren't teachers
willing to help do you remember I think
it was during the pandemic there were
the bunch of illegals uh kids who came
in it was in San Francisco I believe it
was July and it was their vacation and
they said although they weren't going to
teach the American kids they were going
to teach these illegal kids on their own
time how to read so they can get get
into school easier I mean everything is
backwards and upside down no part of it
incentivizes our kids Piers do you guys
have this problem overseas we do and I
you can chart it all back to egg and
Spoon races do you have those in America
I was great at egg and Spoon never
dropped an egg right and we took it very
seriously and it was really it was a
talent it was a skill and you wanted to
win and then in England they banned egg
and Spoon racist that's when it went
down hill because it I I chart
everything from that I actually want to
blame my country for this because the
moment they did that what they said was
it was getting too competitive and kids
were hurting each other then they banned
The Father's Day race and Mother's Day
races because parents were getting
competitive and the kids would see mommy
or daddy lose and then I realized what
was happening we were moving as a
society that used to celebrate winning
and achievement and success and coming
first and hated losing and coming last
and we were becoming the complete
reverse well now a society that
celebrates losing uh you see people on
Instagram going I'm so proud of myself I
just passed my driving test at the ninth
attempt you're like why did it take you
nine attempts you're a terrible driver
what are you proud of yourself for leave
my wife out of this PCT but that's the
central point of that is until we stop
celebrating weakness and losing this is
the way it's all going to go these kids
are now being told don't worry about
being dumb that's fine but what happens
when they get to The Real World what
happens when they get out of the cotton
wall and they actually have to go and
compete for jobs or compete for whatever
it may be in life they don't have a
competitive bone on their body because
they don't have to have one we have to
bring back a mentality that winning is a
good thing that achievement matters that
actually going to school and being good
and better than people around you is a
good thing something to be embarrassed
about they all found jobs though they
found jobs at Disney they found jobs in
anheiser Bush all the places were yeah
light and they take that mentality to
the these corporations and the
corporations see their profits tanking
when they do stupid dumb decisions
because you know what at school they
were told is great to be done MH D well
it's no longer the soft bigotry of low
expectations it's the declared bigotry
of low expectations they just say it out
loud remember Glenn yunan the governor
of Virginia how did he win his race the
number one Applause line that he got was
when he went to every town hall and said
I will increase standards for math and
reading in your schools and he won
overwhelming
it's interesting because when there's a
Republican president everyone's so
concerned about how other countries are
beating us in literacy and math but when
there's a Democratic president we just
like openly say actually black people
brown people you know you're not as good
at this and we're going to take care of
this for you it it robs them of their
right to Pursuit of Happiness I think
it's a civil rights issue and here's
another thing do not ever support free
college until they fix K through2
education because if you fix K through2
education you do not need free college M
and bring back egg and Spoon yes eggs
are so expensive I'll take you on egg
imag how competitive that
would let's do it tomorrow raw egg
spoiled America V Britain okay the
winner gets to stay in that CH okay all
right all right I got it I got it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else